[Music]
while we're on this subject of subatomic
particles and and weirdness I wanted to
I want it if you could illuminate this
often misused explanation for the
observer effect because you know the
particles waves and you watch them
observe them and it changes the reaction
it is heavily misunderstood it's
misunderstood because people want to
attribute it to magic the magic of our
mind the consciousness looking at it but
isn't it in fact just measuring it yes
thank you please explain next question
because I'm so sorry Joe Hey Joe you're
good it just tried you not carry your
people with you I try Wesley with it
weird i know when i'm were you pulling
what what what where you getting your
people I don't know well I don't own
them for sure real owner exactly not my
people they vary greatly probably been
loop them together I know you got it
right have you have an admirably diverse
following and then not many people can
claim that and it's probably cuz of your
diverse profile right I mean Lyman's
open-minded as I can but on top of that
on MRI and you read and you're
thoughtful and you're also on some level
respect you'll hear it somebody out and
you're you know you did you got your MMA
thing so no you you're in a lot of
places in a lot of spaces and that's a
good thing I mean we need more unity in
this world so so well thank you yeah
thank you so please explain what what
what people are getting wrong and
they're very simple much simpler than
you think okay all right you ready yeah
so I'm looking at you the only reason
why I can see you is because there's
light reflecting off of your face your
body into my eyes so there's light oh by
the way this started yeah those are
Hubble photographs oh my gosh yeah those
are images from Hubble and I've walked
in their sheets that you put over the
fluorescent light cover and so when we
look up we actually see the real real
image I'm pretending it's the nice yeah
well it's not a completely camera good
beam recording studio well what I want
to do in the future studio I want to
actually build a glass ceiling and have
a full-scale image high resolution image
of the star
a planetarium yeah you're describing
upwards there exactly call it that it's
a planetarium well something like that
but I just wanted an image you're what
you can you know what you know do better
way to do it don't do better than that
you get a look you just you get a curved
version of those very high-resolution
LEDs curves yeah okay then you put any
image up there you want you know that is
the nice guy tonight it's what the sky
looks like from from Alpha century oh so
like when you go to see one of those
star shows at a planetarium and they
show it on the ceiling above you well
yes but nowadays that the ceiling itself
is the is the source of light right not
projected from something right so then
you just feed that with image data and
then it becomes whatever you want
hook me up with someone who knows how to
do that I could totally oh I'm excited
yeah I know you don't know people I got
people I mean people that lend you my
peoples hair you me my people for your
removal your yunano i mean you happy you
know the people of the class that would
teach the people so okay so here is that
looking at you okay all right yes and I
see you I want to know where you are so
I turn on the lights and I say there you
are all right now let's make you tinier
let's make you mini-me okay like in the
movie all right so now there's a tiny
version of you a mini-me version of Joe
Rogan now your little I turn on what
you're still there okay
okay because if the lights are not on I
can't see you I don't know where you are
right it's that simple okay okay when
you start becoming the size of molecules
right on down to the size of an atom and
I ask the question where is Joe Rogan
the atom and I turn on the light to see
you there
because I think you're there so like the
photon comes in hits your atom and pops
you into another location mmm the very
act of trying to measure your position
prevents me from measuring your position
and as have jack [ __ ] to do with your
consciousness or your mind or your eyes
or anything
has to do with the fact that to know
you're there some information has to
come from you to me like shining a light
on you and the small you are the more
susceptible you are to the the energy of
the light changing your position in
space so my question is I was like you
know what you know it's like you ever I
don't know if this is still happened
your quarter spills out of your pants
pocket on the backseat of a car and is
there in the wedge between the bottom
and the backseat and so you try to reach
in to get it and the act of reaching for
the coin makes the coin move farther
away from you
the act of reaching for it right because
you're so separated and it just slides
down even further
that's not your mind making that happen
it's the it's the act of the measurement
that is affecting what it is you're
trying to measure and this was
discovered in quantum physics and to the
point where that's actually it's a
Heisenberg uncertainty principle it's
one of the basic foundations of all of
quantum physics
[Music]